I'm gonna be completely honest I do not
know how the YouTube algorithm is gonna
deal with this video because the title
of this movie is black clansmen spelt
like this in which case these letters in
sequence are part of the title in
respect to the filmmaker respect to
Spike Lee that's how he wants the title
to be I will have the title like that in
this video so the YouTube algorithm
might bury the video my dia monetize it
I don't know we'll see what happens
[Music]
black clansmen so black clansmen is the
insane true story taking place in 1979 a
black cop officer ron Stallworth played
by john david washington yes that is
Denzel Washington son and he's great in
the movie sometimes when we talk to you
like that is Denzel he essentially
answers an ad in the paper for the Ku
Klux Klan so he infiltrates the Ku Klux
Klan which when I heard the promise I
was like is it a comedy like Clayton
Bigsby from Chappelle's Show it is not a
comedy it is a very heavy drama it does
have comedy in it and I appreciated that
but unless the Klan went completely
blind in the 70s he couldn't show up to
meet them so he talks to them on the
phone and Adam drivers character he goes
and meets that so both of them
essentially play the same person for the
most part I've really enjoyed this movie
like I said it's heavy I mean the
content is very heavy it's mostly heavy
because you know for a fact this movie
is a message to today to modern-day to
us because those who don't learn from
history are doomed to repeat it and the
hate circle it's still there you look
online on social media on Twitter
whatever you just feel like we're going
in a circle as we circle the drain down
the toilet bowl and while I have made
videos in the past talking about how I
don't feel every movie needs a political
or social message in it sometimes a
movie needs to be an escape it escapism
is real black clansmen is not one of
those movies you go to to escape I mean
when I saw the trailer I was like that
movie's going to have a message is gonna
be very relevant to today if you don't
think that going into this movie you're
fooling yourself in fact it should be
one of the reasons you go to this movie
so if you don't like that or don't want
that you have been warned
what the movie does very well is it does
show sides I mean it's not like a wolf
done the Klan they're just doing their
thing hate but you know perspective it's
not like that they do show them all
meeting and they do come across you just
like oh hi Chuck you have some burgers
because you can't really pick out a
bigot you can't go to the mall and just
be like that's a racist that's not a
racist doesn't work like that but also
the Black Panthers are a part of this
movie and when Ron Stallworth is talking
from someone from the Black Panthers
that is a very fascinating conversation
because conversation is well you're the
enemy and he's like I'm a cop and I'm
trying to do good I'm trying to help you
so I really liked the movie Illustrated
sometimes people who are fighting for
the same thing just see each other as
the enemy the movie does have a couple
of Donald Trump references and oh some
people just say they knock a lot date
back when they hear that but I felt like
it was within character David Duke in
this movie played by Topher Grace I
thought I did a great job too maybe dude
being the former leader of the Ku Klux
Klan but David Duke in real life has
said he likes
like he's advocated for Trump so when
David Duke in this movie makes a
reference about one day someone will be
in office that makes America great again
I don't think David Duke said the words
make America great again in 1979
obviously David Duke likes Trump so we
must have something in his mind at some
time that Trump would then later say
that would click with him so it's just
showing that connection so it's within
character not like the purge marketing
department trying to play up to make
America great again thing where I'm like
that's a mag a hat and the Trump
administration is not going to make the
purge happen you're just over reaching
purge movies I do feel things got really
real in the end credits but I also feel
like he really stuck that landing with
the end credits or it was right before
the end credit it shows real footage of
recent times and your force it just
gives you pause you have to think about
it just like Spike Lee was like no we're
gonna have this conversation because
we've been having the conversation for a
little over two hours now here's the
cherry on top you have to ask after that
[ __ ] in Charlottesville Virginia like
why couldn't the president just get up
there and be like all black people out
there know this we are not going back in
time please do not be afraid of that we
are moving forward we are a progressive
nation when I said I wanted to make
America great again what I meant was
take it back to the booming economy I
did not mean I was gonna isolate you
please know that we will make America
better than before with everybody as
equals including you [ __ ] the Ku Klux
Klan like why couldn't you just say that
I don't get too political I'm here but
but why message aside as a movie
narrative Lee speaking I thought the
movie was actually it was very engaging
it's not the most exciting thing ever
but when Adam driver is there amidst
this Ku Klux Klan rally you're just like
don't get caught at all I did appreciate
the humor when it was in everything like
I said this movie is not a comedy it is
a drama the movie is so applicable the
modern day sometimes it just feels heavy
and with that heaviness you need
something you need to laugh sometimes
the movie gives you a few chuckles now
and then I appreciated that because life
has chuckles no matter what like there's
nothing on earth no form of
entertainment no medium has so perfectly
blended all genres as well as life
itself has so when a drama has comedy
it's just life I do feel like the movie
has some pacing issues sometimes I mean
the movies 2 hours 20 minutes near the
end the last third of the movie I was
like this is dragging on you could pick
it up whereas I feel like that should
have been sped up there are some times
with the girlfriend who is a part of the
Black Panthers she's great when she's on
screen but I forget about her when she's
not and then the movie goes back to her
after a long
oh yeah that's right she's a part of it
I felt like that was a little uneven and
there were some stylistic choices when
the intense thing is happening when it
is going down it's it's 70s music which
it takes place in the 70s should make
sense but when watching it it just
doesn't I just imagined more intense
music playing and I would have been on
the edge of my seat it's not the only
questionable stylistic choice in this
movie this Black Panther leader is
talking he's giving a speech you're like
it was a very engaging speech but it
cuts to the audience listening to it but
it's not the audience really it's
certain heads in the audience that are
like fading in and out there's a strange
cult guys in the end I really enjoyed
black Klansmen it's an insane tale
that's a true story everyone did a great
job in an atom drivers fantastic John
David Washington want to see more of him
the movies not perfect but it sticks the
landing of its message it was engaging
it was thrilling at times and I
personally thought it was a great time
no alcohol required there was actually a
really great philosophical moment that
lends itself to a debate and here he's
talking about this movie Birth of a
Nation I've never seen it but apparently
it really empowered the Ku Klux Klan so
this movie changed the world in which
case you could argue art changes reality
but the phrase has always been art
imitates reality so if reality is
changed by art but then art imitates
reality it is very circular it's like
the source of the reflection becoming
the reflection it just goes back and
forth that is another conversation for
the people to have at their whim all
right so black Klansmen have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]